alright good afternoon everybody happy
Earth Day appears yes that's what Fred
this is this is the earth day
spectacular lecture I'm Doug Rogers from
the Department of Anthropology it's my
pleasure to introduce our speakers today
simony how and Dominic Boyer let me
first thank the Department of
Anthropology colloquium series and the
Yale climate and energy Institute's
lecture series called nature culture
action which has been run this year to
great success by City Randall and Chris
hebden nine lectures wasn't 989 an
enormous amount of work so thank you
guys for putting that together and I
understand there will be more next year
so stay tuned so many how is an
associate professor of anthropology at
Rice University where she also teaches
in the women's gender sexuality studies
program she's done fieldwork in
Nicaragua for over a decade and this is
the subject of her 2013 book intimate
activism sexual rights in
post-revolutionary Nicaragua which
traces the long and ultimately
successful struggle to repeal the most
repressive anti-sodomy law in the
Americas I have not managed to read the
book myself yet but I can give you an
even better recommendation which is that
people are talking about this book I
heard about it from from multiple
independent sources who tell me that
this is an important and
methodologically innovative and
enormously imaginative study of the in
the Anthropology of activism and LGBTQ
rights and sexuality Dominic Boyer is
professor of anthropology at Rice
University Dominic as many of you know
is one of anthropology's foremost
experts on expertise as well as
intellectuals and professionals more
broadly especially in the fields of
journalism and media but across the
whole number of domains these long-term
interests have taken him to a wide
variety of directions from his first
book spirit in system on German
intellectual culture to his third book
just published last year an entitled
life the life informatik about the
transformations that accompany digital
media in the US and Europe in between
he's fun to write found time to write on
an extraordinary range of topics
including an article which I'll be
teaching later this week in which with
which I always conclude my
graduate class on the former Soviet
Union this is an article that some of
you have probably read in cultural
anthropology that compares late soviet
political satire this is co-written with
alexa your truck and liberal political
satire notably the colbert report and
things like this it's a great article to
teach and fantastically insightful a
better whole number of things over the
past few years simony and dominic have
been working on a new and shared set of
interests that they're going to talk
about today about energy inoue in Oaxaca
and in anthropology more generally
before they do that though the last
thing I want to mention is that even as
they develop this new field of research
and even as they have taken on
two-thirds of the editorial director
responsibilities that cultural
anthropology in recent times they have
been instrumental in putting together
Rice's Center for the enter for Energy
and Environmental Research and human
sciences which Dominic now direction
they've both been heavily involved in
this is the first energy studies center
in the US that is based in the
humanities and humanistic social
sciences rather than the more
traditional physical sciences and
engineering fields I was there a couple
of years ago when it was just getting
started and I can tell you what a unique
and stimulating intellectual experience
it was for me to give a paper and then
to be involved in a day's worth of
papers and conversations that included
people in religion and english and all
sorts of humanities fields rather than
the more hard or social science ii and
natural science ii conversations with
that which i've become used to so so
this is terrific the center continues to
grow by leaps and bounds so if you are
interested in or working on energy keep
your eyes on some mini dominic and rice
without further ado looking I don't know
if we probably don't need to worry too
much about miking this I suppose but
Elizabeth this year thank you so much
dog that was so touching us tears in my
eyes and and on Earth Day no less to
have such wonderful words of praise and
thanks also to Chris to Ryan to Sadie
and everyone else who helped make it
possible for us to come here it's a
great treat to come to Yale it seems
like Spring has finally come to after
what we understand was a very long hard
northern winter
congratulations for having made it
through as doug said this is a
collaborative project front to finish
and we've sort of into the final laps of
it I guess all we have to do just write
those books now and those books are
going to take an interesting form that
we're happy to talk more about later on
we're going to do a do a graph rather
than two monographs and we'll happy to
explain what that means so this is sort
of a piece that's drawn from that
process of beginning to come back from a
year's a very exciting challenging field
research come to terms with some of the
bigger issues that came up in that
research and so will give the the
presentation essentially in two parts
i'll give the first part in simony will
give the second and then we're really
looking forward to your feedback so
let's start off with an encounter with
transnational green capitalism on the
frontier of Mexican statecraft it
happened in February 2013 in Oaxaca ziz
miss of tehuantepec where a state police
checkpoint had been set up just before
the road from the district capital who
cheat on turns southeast toward the
village of alvaro obregon checkpoint
somewhat overstates the formality of the
situation there were a few state police
trucks Eiling by the side of the road
near several weathered wooden canoes
signs of having crossed over into the
fishing zone of the Laguna superion the
police half-heartedly reviewed our
papers but only because we ask senior
Tomas our taxi driver for the day to
stop the car a representative of the
walk and government had told us that
morning that the situation in Aveiro was
very tense the police were reporting
trucks filled with men driving around
the village brandishing sticks and
machetes threatening violence say no
Tomas by contrast assured us that we had
very little to worry about driving
through the verdant ranch land south of
who cheat on he had explained how
resistance is always tied to money in
the isthmus he said this is how it
always is people make a lot of noise
about this or this other thing but it's
just because they want to be paid and
when they get paid all this resistance
will dry up you'll see well we didn't
expect to see on that road and the
reason why we asked see no Tomas to pull
over were two Gringo's talking to the
local police commander the tall one
turned out to be someone we'd been
pursuing for some time Android Chapman
part of the senior management team of
Marina renova blaze a consortium seeking
to build the largest single phase wind
park in all of Latin America 132
turbines with a production capacity of
396 megawatts enough electricity to
power nearly half a million homes but
everyone around who cheat on knew that
morenia was in deep trouble it's park
was designed to stretch across a sandbar
at the southern end of the Laguna from
the benissa or zapotec community of
Alvaro across to the aquatic immunities
of Santa Maria del Mar and San Dionisio
Demma originally scheduled for
completion by the end of 2012 the
project suffered delay after delay
before becoming the focal point for
resistance movement against wind power
organized by popular assemblies assembly
as populares across the luenell area and
you see here the sites in which the
marina project was to be built the
assembly Azhar as simony will discuss in
more detail community level
self-governance projects united against
all governmental and industrial mega
proyectos or mega projects in the region
by the end of 2012 blockades had been
erected both in Alvaro and in Sandy
inizio to prevent the inception of
marinas construction crisis ensued
indeed just the day before a taxi ride
the president of marinas Board of
Directors Jonathan Davis our sack had
threatened that the company and what
they estimated to be a 13 billion peso
or nearly 1 billion dollar investment
would leave Oaxaca unless what he
described as rule of law could be
guaranteed Davis claimed that there were
only 20 well identified people resisting
this park what he and the Oaxacan news
media characterized as a violent and
unscrupulous minority of political
opportunists most of them not even from
the region who were blackmailing project
developers morenia was unwilling or
unable to believe that large numbers of
his menos would reject a project that
the developers viewed as hugely
beneficial to them this is a
computer-generated graphic of what the
barra the sandbar might have looked like
had the project been built even if we'd
become to be suspicious about the public
minimization and demonization of the
opposition movement we found it hard not
to sympathize with Chapman personally he
spoke to us openly shouting himself
hoarse over the wind he seemed like a
man desperate to be heard
quote my job is to go in there and try
to open a dialogue and to go listen but
I can't do that with threats of violence
the only way to change minds is to
listen to people but if you're not
allowed to listen to people what do you
do we got this project that I really
believe is good for the planet good for
the region good for the people down here
and the people Chapman felt sure would
come around he continued you can't help
but be stunned by the beauty of this
place and then you see how the people
are living and I'm trying not to just
impose my American values here but I
don't think lousy medical care is a good
thing that lousy schools are a good
thing so if you can funnel resources
into these communities to improve those
services imagine where they could be in
five or ten years they can be fishing
the lagoons but they'd have basic stuff
like electricity that's continuous like
transportation like schools it may sound
very idealistic but that's actually what
we're trying to do and to be confronted
with this violence and with people who
are essentially lying about what we're
trying to accomplish he trailed off the
conflict obviously wearying him and a
moment later he concluded i just find it
frustrating frustrating and sad and the
consequence is that the investor group i
represent they're sitting in their
offices in New York and they can put
their money here they can put their
money there and they're just going to
say to themselves why I don't need these
problems i'm not actually in the
business of saving the world I'm in the
business of earning money for my
fiduciaries and I need to do that in a
low-risk way more bad news k minutes
later from the police there was no way
they were going to advise chapman to
enter other oh that day the risks were
as predicted too high the state police
have come to treat those opposing the
wind park with a great deal of caution
memories are still fresh of the previous
November when morenia and the police
tested the alvaro blockade during the
day of the dead festival when many in
the resistance were elsewhere attending
to the graves of deceased family and
friends with several protesters hauled
off to detention in who cheat on and
others quieted with pepper spray the
blockade was temporarily broken allowing
company workers to access the sandbar
and begin topographic and vegetation
removal work but only hours later a much
larger crowd of several hundred rally to
chase the police and company off
overturning trucks and taking
construction equipment hostage we
arrived in Oberoi only minutes after the
police sped out of town to find the
opposition more galvanized than ever one
of the leaders told us machete
his hip if they want to see blood here
we are we're ready the police never
quite found the nerve to come back and
construction on the marina renova blaze
Park is still not as of today begun
indeed it seems increasingly likely that
it will never begin and that the project
will fail despite strong support from
all levels of the Mexican government and
generous international financing despite
new policy regimes favorable to
renewable energy development despite
almost uniformly positive media coverage
in the national and regional press and
despite the leverage of powerful
international investors including the
Australian investment bank Macquarie and
of Japanese firm Mitsubishi the marriage
of Mexico's aggressive renewable energy
campaign its high electricity tariffs
and the world-class wind resources of
the Isthmus seem to all parties to be
highly auspicious in a matter of less
than a decade more than a dozen wind
parks have come on grid in Mexico
according to industry experts the
densest development of wind energy
anywhere in the world investors continue
to flock to the isthmus while
International Renewable Energy advocates
have lauded will Huck and wind power
development for its positive
contributions to climate change the
marina project alone could have offset
up to 879 thousand tons of carbon
dioxide a year but marina is above all a
story about impasse and failure and in
this paper we'd like to explore the
reasons why such a diverse lee supported
an ecologically timely project never
came to be staying true to the
complexity of the case in lieu of an
argument for a single decisive causality
we offer a bundle of reflections on the
diverse challenges facing programs of
energy transition especially in parts of
the world like the isthmus of
tehuantepec that have long been
marginalized or abandoned by their
governing states of course it's no
secret that large-scale projects of
energy development are often
controversial especially when the
intense energy needs of trans local
governance in industry are perceived as
threatening local sovereignty and
interests and mexico has been no
stranger to such conflicts until the
1980s for example Mexico the largest
population displaced by hydropower
projects anywhere in the world but the
Isthmus of Tehuantepec also has a long
political and cultural history of
resistance to the hegemony of oaxaca
valley elites and to the nationalist
overtures
arms of Mexico City few histories of the
isthmus formal or informal do not invoke
andrian scribe a NIST may no tradition
of struggle against external power
narratives often begin before the
Spanish conquest with his menos depicted
as the last true Zapotecs after the
Aztecs made the northern Zapotecs their
minions assimilating them culturally and
linguistically then one is reminded of
revolt after revolt in the 19th century
of how national and Oaxacan hero oaxacan
hero Benito Juarez never broke the will
of who cheat on even though he burned it
one here's how brave who cheat echoes
later fought valiantly against the
French invasion of Mexico and helped
secure the victory of the Mexican
Revolution but when that national
revolution turned corrupt in the second
half of the 20th century its main use
rose again with their peasant and
student movement cosa e helping to
accelerate the dissolution of the pre
party state in the 1980s in all such
stories the isthmus is frequently
identified as the place where the
sovereign powers of Oaxacan state and
Mexican national governance and where as
in other Obregon the police fear to
tread yet marinas impasse also has
reasons quite contemporary illuminating
deep tensions and paradoxes and dominant
paradigms of renewable energy
development across the world as
elsewhere neoliberalism market and
entrepreneurial or into oriented
approaches to energy transition or
trumpet is as the most effective in
rational solutions to anthropogenic
climate change large-scale renewable
energy projects like wind parks are also
highly capital intensive and thus become
tightly bound to finance capitalism and
to expectations for a positive return on
shareholder investment thus even though
green energy projects typically speak a
language of environmental sustainability
the growth imperative of dominant models
of economic health bleeds over into and
directs them communities perhaps
especially indigenous communities with
resources like land water and wind that
can be harnessed for renewable energy
mega projects often find their own
interests averted to those states to
those of states and corporations
desperately searching for an alchemy of
growth profit and sustainability in the
shadow of the Anthropocene and there are
more complications still walk and wind
power development needs to be understood
not only as a response to climate change
but
also to the vulnerability of the Mexican
Petro State although peak oil fears have
dissipated in some countries with the
rise of shale oil and gas extraction in
Mexico such concerns remain both strong
and empirically substantiated Mexican
heavy crude production fell forty six
percent from 2004 2012 with its only
super giant field cantarell running dry
and the national oil monopoly petroleos
mahut Co Pemex why they believed to lack
the expertise and resources to
effectively develop deep water
hydrocarbon resources the Mexican Petro
State the finds itself at its own
crossroads in recent years Pemex is
supplied as much as forty percent of the
operating budget of the Mexican federal
government meaning that all aspects of
Mexican state craft all these wonderful
bio political interventions they all
depend critically upon revenue from oil
sales the crude production drop has been
masked to some extent by the concomitant
rise in international oil prices which
is allowed Pemex to retain high revenue
but put bluntly the current financial
model for the Mexican state is only one
big drop in the international price of
oil away from disaster President Felipe
Calderon's pushed to rapidly develop
renewable energy resources was
formulated in this context as an
official in the Mexican environmental
environmental ministry cynare explained
to us quote we need to diversify the
sources of our electricity production
the hydrocarbons we don't use for our
own energy consumption are hydrocarbons
we can sell at a good price this is what
I have termed an Ergo politics in action
fuel and electricity guiding the
operation of political power from within
in the fading light of the Black Sun of
oil new and ergo political models are
emerging as part of a massive but still
aptly subterranean effort to sustain the
petro political growth model in mexican
mexico political interest in the wind
resources of the Isthmus of Tehuantepec
dates back to the early 1990s however
was only during kada runs presidency
when drug cartel powers sword and oil
began to wane that a serious campaign to
develop renewable energy began new
legislation was passed demanding
thirty-five percent clean electricity by
2024 alongside lucrative incentives for
new private public partnerships in
renewable
development the Mexican wind power
center exploit the Mexican wind power
sector exploded in 2008 there were only
two parks producing 84.9 megawatts four
years later there were 15 parks
producing over thirteen hundred
megawatts a 1467 percent increase that
made Mexico the second biggest wind
power producer in Latin America after
Brazil the dominant development scheme
has been industrial self supply autobus
nacimiento partnerships in which a
private wind developer contracts to
produce energy for a large industrial
clients such as sem x walmart or fem so
heineken over a period of decades these
schemes are typically portrayed as
win-win-win for the government
developers in industry companies can
lock in lower than market energy prices
for a long term enjoy the financial
benefits of carbon credits and guarantee
themselves secure energy supply
developers enjoy special financing
through schemes like the UN's Clean
Development Mechanism and states receive
infrastructural development in economic
multipliers without having to invest
themselves communities are also
frequently portrayed as winners and self
supply development in that they
typically receive land rents and
payments from use of fructose area
agreements but many esteem a nose have
come to doubt the benefits of auto Busta
Simeon to wind development and the
marina project has helped to focus these
doubts and distill them into resistance
for several reasons first morenia is
viewed by its critics as epitomizing a
general lack of transparency in the
development process what is now known as
the marina renova blaze project has
shifted owners names and footprints
several times since development began in
2003 speculative activity was quite
common in the early days of the Oaxacan
wind rush and we discovered significant
evidence of a cartel like organization
either created or simply tolerated by
the Oaxacan state government in which
wind developers were assigned exclusive
negotiation rights over choice plots in
the core wind zone many of these plots
were flipped at a profit again and again
without informing the communities which
would be impacted communities were
meanwhile never allowed to entertain
competitive bids from different
developers which set remuneration rates
at a low level by international standard
also speculators knowing that they would
not have to see these projects through
to operation frequently cut corners
in terms of community relations and
engagement years later many as menos
complained of having been given
insufficient or inaccurate information
regarding the impacts that projects
would bring in December 2012 a federal
judge issued an injunction on Pato to
halt progress on the marina park in
order to investigate opposition claims
that indigenous land was being
expropriated without prior information
and consent a second criticism
frequently raised against morenia is
that it has sought like many wind
developers to advance its project
through manipulation of local
authorities rather than through
consensus building projects with whole
communities companies fervently deny
these claims but critics contend that
contracts for exploration and land use
rights were facilitated by bribes paid
to mayors and Comus ariados collective
land commissioners in the form of cash
or trucks there are wonderful tales of
mysterious trucks disgorging still more
mysterious men roaming toilet streets
with suitcases filled with cash and even
when local authorities are not
personally implicated in bribery or
embezzlement it's said that they share
their new resources only within their
own political Network thus effectively
privatizing what had been initially
promised as a broader social good this
points to a third general area of
complaint that wind development in the
isthmus has accentuated social
inequality political polarization and
violence by deep prioritizing general
social benefits in other words these
same biopolitical schools in health care
mentioned by chapman in favor of
benefits to land holders here is where
most of the land rents in the wind zone
are being concentrated in new luxury
homes also cars for the land owning
class wind is a lucrative business for
local elites and funds political
campaigns and machines and towns where
votes are openly sold for 600 pesos or
about forty five dollars a head it's
also good business for the construction
unions who have in several cases
provided groups of Gopi Edoras thugs to
intimidate threaten in some cases
physically attack those who resist or
oppose wind part projects the marina
project also possesses several
singularities that have helped make it a
watershed case it's uniquely impactful
and that it would be the first part to
affect a plurality of Laguna communities
all of which have traditional rights of
access to fishing near the sandbar
likewise it would be the first Park to
occupy land it actively administered as
bns Coleman honest as common rather than
private property in all other cases when
parks of occupied land that have been
privatized whether voluntarily or by
force it's also apparently the only wind
farm project in the world designed to
occupy a sandbar thus making its
environmental impacts especially
difficult to estimate there's little
comparative evidence available for
example to address locally burning
questions such as whether the presence
of the turbines would create vibrations
and shed light that would scare fish
away however there is one causality that
stands out prominently from the pack is
the most immediate reason for morenia
sale yer the rise of the popular
assembly network I mentioned a few
minutes ago deserving far more than this
brief mention simony will now turn to a
deeper analysis of the origins and goals
of the anti Iola Corps anti-wind as they
call themselves resistance movement okay
back at the crossroads of green
capitalist development and aspirations
and the barricades of alvaro obregon one
is struck by the sheer quantity of dust
that arises when trucks roll down the
road it is reason enough to wrap a
handkerchief or a t-shirt around any and
all orifices and Men in oviedo are often
outfitted this way bare chested with a
thin in t-shirt shrouding nose and mouth
just to keep the dirt out maybe the
protective shirt is printed with the
smiling face of a bygone political
candidate or maybe it is a rock and roll
concert relic in either case the chronic
cough that is audible everywhere in this
little hamlet makes it seem as though
this is a losing battle today in front
of the abandoned Hacienda that the
resistance has appropriated as their
meeting place t-shirts have been
fashioned into masks by a group of young
men with a more symbolic purpose
signaling a touch of outlaw parton
zapatista and part universal gangster as
they jump down from the back of a white
pickup truck even the t-shirt masks
can't conceal the young men smiles
they've just returned from an excursion
to the site where marina has its test
tower a spindle a metal steeple with a
three-pronged wind vane to meter the
quality duration and force of the wind
the masked men have something in hand a
prize the crowd numbering 70 or so soon
gather
eager to see what this was passing the
booty from hand to hand with care the
object finally got close enough for us
to see that it was a gauge of some kind
with settings and indicators in English
and numbers on dials it fell down they
explained to us from the tower
incredulous we asked it fell down with
their smiles grow imperceptibly wider
they had decided that the bluff was not
really worth pursuing any longer well
they concluded it fell down when we
pulled down the tower marina project may
have a powerful set of allies and all of
the forces of transnational capital
behind it but it certainly does not have
the approval of the men in the t-shirt
masks the anti wind resistance has been
able to catalyze challenges to wind
energy development across the isthmus in
part because they have raised explicit
critiques of neoliberal forms of
development and foreign financial
intervention but as we will detail here
the resistance has also found a
political purchase not because it
opposes renewable energy they do not but
because they have surface concerns about
both the potential social and
environmental consequences that may
follow in the wake of the wind parks
construction the resistance has codified
a suite of concerns that range from the
displacing and destructive potential of
mega projects to worries about the loss
of land and fish la laguna la pesca en
nuestra tierra el lagoon the fish on our
land have become effectively aligned in
order to gesture to bajillion practices
and regional patrimony as local
residents call attention to
environmental and social precarious that
they believe the wind parks portend
these eco social alignments have also
engendered distinct ways of imaginary
imagining and articulating what I have
been calling antipas Enoch eco Authority
a series of experiential scientific and
managerial truth claims regarding
ecological knowledge and future
forecasting in an era of global
anthropogenic change as it is enunciated
by resident communities or state
officials corporate representatives or
environmental experts Anthropocene akiko
Authority fine
traction by asserting ethical claims on
behalf of and in regards to the
anthropogenic ly altered future of the
biosphere both human and non-human as
the climate scholar Mike whom has
predicted more generally climate change
mitigation measures like those we have
seen in Mexico have indeed fomented new
opportunities for environmental
consciousness and activism however it
has not been the sort of environmentally
oriented response that the marina
consortium or the Mexican state has
hoped for although transitions to
renewable energy have the ethical
potential to leverage a global climate
illogical good when they are seen to
contravene local claims for rights
autonomy environmental knowledge and
ecological stewardship they instead
generate as marina has found the
conditions for failure our argument then
is that where climate mitigation efforts
and renewable energy transitions are
coupled with neoliberal development
logics we are likely to find resistance
reinvented in collaborative and lateral
lyst modes of activists response the
office of the assembly of indigenous
peoples of the isthmus in defense of
land and territory is readily identified
on the streets of who cheat on it is the
one with the anti wind turbine stencils
on its facade as you see here as we sat
down one Sunday afternoon with two of
the founders of the resistance and a
couple of other attentive listeners it
was hard not to notice our intimate
physical proximity zin this tiny room
decorated with images of past victories
and he rose from J to L subh that
supplement the Marcos of the Zapatista
uprising Roberto began our conversation
and proceeded to detail the historical
narrative of the resistance over the
course of over an hour roberto is one of
the primary voices of the resistance he
does not however like to be called a
leader this is a designation that he
associates with hierarchical Vanguard
'used and ultimately corrupt political
forms roberto is a teacher by vocation
and by nature as became clear in his
oration of these historical events the
resistance against Marina he explained
must be understood through a longer
genealogy that spans many decades and
locations in addition to the
insurrectionary politics of the isthmus
particularly the early cause a movement
that Dominic mentioned earlier Roberto
linked to the resistance to the
repression of the student movement in
Mexico City in 1968 and a guerrilla
insurgency in Chihuahua before that he
referenced the Chi open rebellion of the
summit east as following the North
American Free Trade Agreement and the
battle over the development of an
airport in a tenko just outside of
Mexico City he likewise saw though anti
wind resistance as linked to the
teachers strike and state violence in
the capital of Oaxaca in 2006 guided by
Oppo the popular assembly of the peoples
of Oaxaca and finally to maoism itself
with its agrarian peasant insurgencies
and challenges to first world
imperialism so Roberto's cartography of
revolution and response to foreign
domination urban hegemony and rebellions
against neoliberal development brought
us to the origins of the anti wind
resistance in 2005 it was founded he
explained by a group of committed
teachers he and others had protested
against the installation of a wind park
in La Venta small town in the 1990s
noting that subcomandante marcos himself
had shown up to speak in solidarity with
them beyond the symbolic gestures of the
Sapa tease the leadership the assembly
of indigenous peoples could also claimed
several significant victories of their
own these included nullifying wind park
contracts across the Isthmus region and
as Roberto put it rescuing two thousand
one thousand two hundred hectares of
land from being contracted and thus
turned into wind parks Roberto gives
credit where credit is due he is
faithfully citation ille as he narrates
the insurrectionary lineage of the
resistance originally the who cheat on
arm of the opposition worked under the
name the people's front in defense of
land and territory however Roberto
explained the designation of front
orford anything is overly encumbered by
vanguard ism hierarchical leadership and
a military etymology all qualities that
they hope to surpass by consensus it was
decided that the title of assembleia
better captured their ethos an assembly
of Oaks as Roberto put it a more
egalitarian notion that of community he
went on to explain quote we have
traversed the entire hist
Oracle process of the left in Mexico in
order to be able to offer an alternative
and quote a communitarian ethos and
horizontal or lateral leadership along
with collective consensus is emphasized
in both the name assembly as well as in
the spirit of the project refusing
leadership and leaders and therefore
implicitly a flock of followers
dedication to the collective model is
also manifest in the deeds of the
resistance it would prioritize founding
more assemblies as a central part of
their mission assembly as Hannah Dallas
have since multiplied across the Isthmus
in towns and villages supporting the
anti marini resistance these working
forms of protest and process call for
collective decision-making in a
reinvented use of soc costumbres which
is literally customs and practices
illegal and social system operating in
parallel to state governance in Mexico
and other parts of Latin America leukoc
costumbres in general have been regarded
as a counterbalance to indigenous
peoples marginalization and elite
national projects in Mexico and
elsewhere and while the resistance has
fostered collaborations that traverse
historical divisions between local
indigenous populations they have also
managed to navigate political party
lines given the historical strength and
chauvinism of party politics in Mexico
it is no mean feat for PRI party
loyalists to share meals with the
leftist revolutionary democratic party
or the prd and the co SE e since the
political parties left and right how for
the most part been in favor of the
marina project the parties themselves
have lost favor in the eyes of these
manuals of the resistance in fact they
have gone so far as to summarily
question the validity of political
parties as legitimate democratic
institutions altogether Antonio is one
of the founders of the assembly and
Alvaro and one of the key voices of the
resistance and he explained speaking to
a crowd one afternoon in front of the
Hacienda that today is a declaration of
war against the political parties
against the government against marina
renova blaze against anyone who is
allied with or affiliates with Mourinho
renova blaze Antonio and others in the
resistance also publicly announced that
no political party candidate would be
allowed to campaign
for political office in the upcoming
municipal elections and in June of 2013
they make good on this pronouncement by
prohibiting the installation of voting
machines in the municipality the parties
and the park have become a combined
Menace for those in the resistance and
so both have been given a directive and
a direction and that direction is wetta
or out the political menace and social
disks equilibria that the wind park
threatens is a critical element of the
opposition's discourse and their
activism however the impacts upon the
environment and subsistence and the
Isthmus are equally resonant in the
opposition's claims against the park the
precise effect that the marina project
might have on fish or shrimp population
of the lagoon and coastal waters is
unclear given the environmental impact
report failed to treat this aspect of
the regional conditions and the
project's unique placement on the
sandbar however in part because of this
absence of scientific analysis fears do
abound the fisherman with whom we spoke
across the Isthmus region were convinced
that their lives and their livelihoods
would be irrevocably impaired by the
development of the wind park ibrahim who
would emerge as one of the key voices of
the resistance in sandy inizio Del Mar
summarized the sentiments of many in the
region when he explained the following
the wealth of our sea of our people of
our source of work and nourishment is
vital if the wind project comes in we
will be buying foreign products come in
from other places which will make
feeding ourselves more expensive and so
in a sense sandy inizio now sees itself
or has transformed itself into a
courageous town that defends its lands
and teaches foreigners that our lands
must be respected so it is telling that
Ibrahim begins his comments with the
riches of our c4 over time as the
resistance to the project grew and
spread we began to hear increasingly the
expression el mod es nuestro Bunco that
is the sea as our bank this was a canny
spin on the evident presence or perhaps
better put in position of banking
interests and multinational capital that
have back to the marina project however
the sentiment that our seat that the sea
is our bank is also a factual statement
to a degree according to reports there
are 5,000 indigenous
families that rely on fishing for their
existence even if the number of families
in Sandy inizio who survive exclusively
by fishing are likely more no more than
a few dozen many if not the majority of
the population rely on fishing for a
kind of security subsistence in
conditions of economic and food and
security if all else fails the sea is
there and you and your family can eat
Ibrahim is not naive after all to
underscore how harm to fish and shrimp
stocks will result in increased
dependence on market-based fixed food
supplies and further insertion into a
vast chain of imported products many
advocates Ibrahim included were clear
that opposition to the wind park was not
a refusal of its clean capabilities and
renewable energy aspirations rather they
wanted to mount a warning and protest
against the prioritization of
market-based growth models spreading
across every dimension of daily life in
Mexico Andrew Chapman in his baseball
hat with a thrashing fish embroider
across the front and a young man behind
the makeshift mass with the absconded
wind meter in his hand represent very
different places both metaphorically and
physically Chapman has long since
returned to New York and the young man
with the meter he has likely either
swapping stories with his friends at the
Hacienda that you see here or out on the
water hauling shrimp filled Nets from
the lagoon my moonlight there is no
reason to make speculative parallels
between the very different lives of each
of these men and the economic social and
cultural world worlds that they
represent but it is fair to say that
they do have shared expectations and
parallel hopes for the future if there
were a way to meet at a metaphorical or
actual crossroads each of them is able
to claim a virtuous indeed ethical
position the American bringing
development fomenting markets for
renewable energy use slowing the creep
of global warming and producing profit
for investors committed to
sustainability dias Manuel fighting for
his future on the lagoon and out of his
one-day children challenging foreign
invaders and transnational capital and
working to ensure food sovereignty for
himself his family and the region
critiquing capitalist development and
creating horizontal and collective
political models the anti morena actions
share an affinity with
Verizon's and protests from Tahrir
Square to Zuccotti Park horizontal
networks function in place of
hierarchies consensus democracy replaces
top-down direction and principles of
decentralization become prioritized
reacting to these projects of green
neoliberalism the resistance has been
able to recapitulate the roots of the
anti-globalization movement and direct
actions that for many originated with
the zapatistas like the Sabattus
malformed in allah condone jungle or the
anti WTO protests in seattle or the
protests against the g8 in Geneva or
most recently to occupy everything
across North Africa and North America
and Europe the resistance has rejected
hierarchical orders and decision making
it has made definitive critiques of
neoliberal policies and the ways in
which private finance capital may
engender local communities livelihoods
and well-being and in this sense we
suggest that energy protest movements
like those in the isthmus represent an
outpost of these sorts of new
opposition's however there are at least
two important distinctions to make
regarding this manual responses to green
neoliberalism that stand apart from
other occupiers anti-globalization
actions and neo anarchist movements that
have merged in other parts of the world
first is their explicit incorporation of
a collaborative neo indigenous
trajectory coupled with an adherence to
a communal ideology of assembly these
tactics have been seen in other Latin
American struggles over sovereignty and
resources to be sure but anti-wind
protest an isthmus signal and emerging
logic of resistance that both rejects
green capitalist aspirations as well as
greenhouse gas reduction as
justification for territorial
displacements the second distinction to
be made is that the resistance in the
isthmus is unlike Occupy not reacting to
a global financial crisis but instead
drawing attention to protracted forms of
marginalization exercised by state
policies and green capitalist developers
in other words they're reminding those
that will listen that they have been the
99 percent for quite some time in fact
the critique being levelled by the
resistance is not aimed at the failure
of global finance capital but rather a
scathing commentary on it's a very
successful propagation across the
isthmus in the form
renewable energy projects in place of
Wall Street banks that were too big to
fail the resistance has challenged a
massive renewable energy installation
that with all of its international
development and corporate sponsorship
has also seemed too big to fail and yet
as of now has so despite the help
Desmarais Nia's clean energy aspirations
the occupations of roads and barricades
that have revealed its stabilities and
its shortcomings and in this sense the
refusal of the marina project is not
simply a referendum on how renewable
energy projects will proceed in Mexico
but a foreshadowing of potential
resistances north and south where
renewable energy projects may
increasingly become objects of dissent
there is likely no one in alvaro obregon
sandy inicio de mar or other communities
around the isthmus who would declare
that outright opposition to preventing
further climate change or in the
broadest terms making the world and
their environment a more humane and more
hospitable place however to entreat them
to sacrifice their land and fishing
grounds on behalf of international
global protocols and climate change
mitigation mandates that are devised in
Kyoto Durban and Copenhagen which in
turn benefit investors and developers at
least as far afield is a proposition
that does not sit well in the isthmus
asking us menus to risk further
precarity on behalf of global warming
and an abstract greater global good may
appear preferable to reenacting
histories of corporate exploitation and
extractivism but this form of engineered
altruism has failed to grain gain much
traction either the marina project has
proven to be a critical referendum on
the possibilities for renewable energy
in Mexico but it is not singular nor
will it be unique as renewable energy
projects continue to expand in Latin
America and around the world it is a
lesson moreover and how disjointed
development and failed attempts at
sustainability resemble other projects
that have similarly taken market-based
models is the only possible
quote-unquote rational solution to the
threats of the Anthropocene perhaps
especially in those places that have
long been refused social goods and
benefits promised by the state we think
these resistances refusals and eco
social responses highlight a very
fundamental
fundamental ethical challenge at the
heart of renewable energy development
but in failure we would argue we also
find opportunity thank you so let me
also just finish with a kind of coda
here and an update as of now as if
mid-2013 the marina projects slowly and
quietly shut down and dispersed from its
its occupation and plans to build on the
sandbar they have since moved in other
directions but rumor has it and it's
only rumor at this point that they have
reconstituted themselves under another
name as has been the history in the
isthmus with many of the same forces of
transnational capital and have moved
inland so that they will they will
produce the park but in a different site
a different location but many of the
same actors so thank you and we look
forward to many questions and thoughts
Shia the woman speaking well thank you
very much for the interesting talk I'm
the question I have is an ethnographic
question about sort of the role of
activist anthropologists when you start
doing ethnographic research that then
complicates some of the maybe the
initial impetus that might have started
an interest in a project and in your
paper the first part when you were
talking about mr. Chapman I became very
interested in how you kind of are eager
to paint him in a favorable light in
some sense in order to prefigure some of
the critiques that you later pose in the
second heart part of the paper and I'm
interested in how you negotiate you know
an anthropological problem where you
don't want to necessarily paint a
picture of you know good versus evil but
at the same time in the end there it
does seem to be a little bit of a
political you know statement that one
wants to make at the same time so I'm
curious how you negotiate that as an
ethnographer began your question in the
discussion was that you know we both
have a strong interest in the transition
to renewable energy from a political
personal point of view we think that
this is something very important that
happened at the global level so part of
the impetus for this project in the
first place was to try and understand
how that transition might happen in a
productive way and then you see a case
like the marina case and other instances
in the isthmus some of which were more
successful than others continuing to
fail it's quite depressing to watch
because you want to see these things
succeed both for local people indigenous
and non-indigenous as well as
potentially for these green developers
who putative Lee want to at least make
more improvements to the world than
their hydrocarbon cousins might shall we
say if not if imperfectly and so there's
a constant sort of back and forth
between those positions the other
important thing and anyone who has done
fieldwork and very hotly contested and
sighs spaces knows that you're either on
one side or the other people understand
you as operating either with us or
against us and so that was a very
difficult balance I think
ethnographically to both be accepted by
the resistance I mean you notice we went
to el vato and we did not we were not
attacked with machetes like they were
worried would happen to Chapman and yet
Chapman is and his interlocutors are
suspicious of anthropology gringo
anthropologists who are investigating
these kinds of politics so you have to
find that that balance between those two
places and yet you know you have sim you
have some respect I think for you know
green development on some level and yet
it's been carried out in a way that's
not that's not a gala Torian and it's
not productive and it's clearly not
working for people on the ground so it's
contrary to its success I guess I would
just add and say that I don't think that
activist anthropology does itself any
favors when it smooths over differences
and glosses the complexities and
paradoxes and part of what's interesting
about this case to us is how paradoxical
certain aspects of an are I mean you
really you sort of want it as an
anthropologist side with both sides for
different reasons and yet the two of
them absolutely a logger heads and it
creates a kind of a somewhat tragic
condition really and but I really feel
as though and we talked about this
endlessly and we've actually written up
a report of how this project could have
succeeded you know there were things
they could have done that would have
made it acceptable to parties there and
in fact there are models that are being
developed in part by other activists for
community-based wind parks that
currently can't operate because of the
way in which even though there's some
really nice things about Mexican
renewable energy laws some of the
requirements for the amount of capital
you have to have in the bank to actually
win a bid to get transmission space on
the grid no poor indigenous community
Mexico could ever hope to raise that
kind of money without you know some
kinds of so so there are models out
there that could that actually could be
you know very specific types of policy
interventions
they could create you know I think
drastically better outcomes and if that
you know if we want to hang our
activists had any where it might be
there so in thinking about the forms of
politics that emerged and what you said
about how the your kind of predicting
after this you're willing to say that
there's something about capitalism and
the forms of kind of the paradoxes of
neoliberal sustainability projects and
that produces certain kind of politics
or that have a relationship to a certain
kind of resistance that takes this form
and I'm curious what you think the
mechanisms of our of that that is I can
see how you know Enterprise
neoliberalism produces and promotes a
form of decentralized of
decentralization and and kind of
fetishizes a certain kind of
participation you know is that is this
in some ways a tick ulation with that
through another mode of decentralization
and participation is it more
oppositional to that like are there I'm
kind of curious how these lock in
together and what the mechanisms you see
are between this kind of paradoxical
neoliberal project and the kinds of
politics it produces I guess so um yeah
there's something generative happening
here and it's a good question to sort of
think about you know where what is you
know where is it actually happening and
so maybe that could also be thought of
if you wanted to as points of
intervention as well as analysis I
really think and somebody mentioned this
you know in her half but I could easily
and i did my have to i suppose but the
the focus on the sort of you know the
market based intervention the growth
model especially it was really
interesting to hear sometimes these very
very young activists who were so like
well okay so we're going to give them
our land they're going to build a wind
park and that energy is going to go
help build a Walmart next door in which
we are going to shop for all of our
things and they said this isn't
sustainable I mean they was like they
could see it which was you know that was
the crux of it for them like this isn't
a sustainable model this is a model that
actually and of course you know this is
sort of the stuff we say up here too in
the north but it was you know for them
it was this you know we have it's it's a
it's a modest life way but we have a way
that's sustainable and many of us you
know enjoy it to some extent and what's
being offered as development is this
particular pathway that both creates
conditions of risk and there was a lot
of talk about while having the fish and
while you know and in you know the park
developers it's crazy the fish won't
even notice he's been parks being there
but so they're all of these sort of
theories of why the fish wouldn't like
the wind parks because of vibration or
light and and so but anyway conditions
of risk is there locally perceived with
no sort of compensatory reward that they
could understand as being beneficial
because really it was just going to lead
to sort of more disposable waste and if
we had been able to show you more
pictures of who cheat on which is the
district capital it's a place that's
like overwhelmed with garbage there's
garbage everywhere and you know
disposable styrofoam plates including it
the place where the aussie Enda is and i
think they sort of saw this as being
like this is the problem right it's not
the wind parks are contributing to that
and that raises the next question which
is well is there an alternative sort of
form of modernity that's being vicious
here that's better than that sort of
market consumption-driven modernity and
that's an interesting question and like
as it so often the case it's unclear and
ambiguous what exactly that alternative
might might involve 21 times yeah i
think that's a fantastic question
actually I mean if I if I heard it right
that kind of a neoliberal model is being
actually mirrored and modeled through
these activists responses right
decentralized maybe not individualized
in the kind of classic neoliberal way
try to you know try and create a more
sort of collective and communal approach
to
but that it's sort of mirroring that
that process and so I think
hypothetically it is discursive Lee and
in the voices of activists they would
refuse that entirely but i think the
other way in which it is neoliberal is
that it has these these processes as
they have unfolded in the marina case
and and others have also increased
social inequality in the region and this
is something that people voice and so
that's another I think another
interesting point where it kind of
Mary's up with this idea of the
neoliberal project writ large right so
that it's landowners with the fancy
houses that are accruing more and more
wealth and more status and so there's a
creating you know more hierarchy more
marginalization among certain
populations and it just sounds just I'm
sorry just parenthetically if this
sounds to you a lot for anyone who knows
Mexico like its participating in a very
like lingerie you know mexican
revolutionary discourse about
overthrowing colonial hierarchies it
absolutely is and it's really a
reference is very clear to them like you
know it's it's about you don't know if
you could see but on the walls is like
you know the zapata lives and things
like that you know everywhere yeah in
the sort of you know the visual language
of the movement so there's a sense in
which they feel as though like every
generation of this has to rise again
against the same forces and that morenia
and its finances are simply the latest
in sensation of this and they will throw
themselves against it to in the hopes of
being able to slow it down or overturn
you know i'll just put another questions
so i have a question that sort of picks
up on these same themes which is I was
really struck both in your analysis
and some of the materials from in fact
the resistance that you showed this how
this concept of alignment is working
both in terms of the eco social
alignments of the lagoon land fish and
and also of I think there was like the
people who are allied or affiliates of
the corporation we're also seen as
what's to be resisted and I'm wondering
I mean I was to wondering if there's
anything besides just a general you
enroll logic responsible for this
resistance that's developed if there I
mean obviously it sounds like this the
inequalities that are developing in the
community are critical for understanding
this and even the sort of generic we or
us who's going to benefit from these
products it's maybe that's differently
experienced by different people like
this you know every if everyone is going
to benefit from it it seems like there's
suspicion that maybe some people will
benefit more than others not you've been
seeing and like the rise of these homes
I'm wondering if they're like new new
sort of like what sort of knew what
whether it's what language we want to
learn use like alliances or publix or
sort of collectives are coming into
being I mean this assembly that's being
formed is is it a recapitulation of
these older politics or is it are we
seeing sort of fundamentally sort of new
coalition's that are being created
through this somehow I guess I mean in
some sense it is a revitalization of
associates to embrace right that exists
in many parts of Oaxaca and other parts
of Mexico as well but has deteriorated
in some pockets of the Isthmus of
Tehuantepec so there's a kind of
revitalization happening around those
particular political practices right
which are sort of customary customary
law is another way of putting it so you
have to two layers of essentially
governance and so there is a rien
vocation of that sometimes it works more
effectively than others but it tries to
be horizontal so that's I think that's
an important piece of it is that they're
trying to sort of reestablish that the
other thing I think is very interesting
that's going on here and we don't get to
this very much in the paper is this kind
of fusion or alliance if we want to use
those terms between human rights
and environmental or ecological rights
the way that the two are being
articulated in ways that bring them
together in a way that they might not
have been able to do before the advent
of the Anthropocene frankly before we
had global discourses about climate
change remediation IPCC reports and
understanding about climate change that
you can even hear people on the ground
who are maybe aren't you know connected
to the media in ways that we are have an
understanding of it and so the the
existence of that or the awareness of
that allows for these fusions between
those two facets i would say that are
generally kept separate so i think when
we hear these stories about you know
what will the fish due to our our
subsistence and our livelihood you're
starting to see some of these
articulations between environment and
human rights so I think that's a very
interesting question and then of course
the larger ethical question about these
spaces where renewable energy projects
are happening they have to happen
somewhere and they often happen in these
more marginalized spaces more rural
spaces where the wind always seems to
blow or the Sun shines they need to
occur someplace and they're probably
invariably human beings living there so
how do you manage those ethical
contingencies between the rights and
desires of local populations who are
either the beneficiaries or the victims
of these projects or maybe something in
between and this larger global claim to
remediate climate change which is at
least putative way for the good of us
all including those local populations
right so there's that there's a
conundrum here and I think that's part
of you know the interesting and also
troubling impasses that we've been
seeing in this project I would just add
briefly that you know it's not
traditional it's it's definitely neo
traditionalist what's going on this
community alvaro that we're talking
about never had to associate custom base
which is really like an alternative to
the political party like the liberal
democratic political but this was a
group it was a community that was
settled by families that had supported a
particular general whose Sen does this
ruin right here so they
you know we're settled there and so in a
way they were part of you know the
modern sort of situation of war and it's
aftermath and so the turn towards
associé customer base is really being
seen as a kind of you know political
intervention against certainly the state
right and against at a moment that you
know they feel that isthmus has been
with all of its riches has long been a
target of all sorts of you know
predatory extractive projects right
going back to like a Panama Canal plan
that went through the region like all
the way you know goes way back so that
that's that and the other thing I'll say
that because this is like you know all
politics is local that part of what was
happening in Alvaro at the time was a
rejection of co say 'yes historical
influence over this area co Seyi was a
kind of a revolutionary movement in
1980s but but it had be it once it once
it sort of successfully challenged the
authority of the pre-party it sort of
its its leaders fell into like
competition with each other and now kind
of run the city of hoochie time kind of
like gangs but it's orderly but it's
like they're different sections of the
city that are controlled by different
sort of mafiosos if you will associate
it with these leaders and one of them
held Alvaro under their grass for many
years and it was used as a cav outing
base for you know this particular
faction to sort of get its part of the
the that's the city finances if you will
and so there was a specific kind of long
history there of like kicking cosa out
kicking the party's out meant rejecting
a sort of vassalage that they felt like
they had been held under and so I mean
that's it's so fine grain but that was
actually a really critical part of this
too
thanks I really enjoyed that a lot I was
just wondering if there you've seen any
resistance to the resistance yet I mean
or in other terms given the growing
social inequalities that you are
alluding to if there are sort of
factional divisions within indigenous
communities in terms of how they think
these issues should be dealt with and I
guess I'm thinking about some of the
critiques that have come out of a lot of
the literature on indigeneity that can
often cast indigenous activists is
relatively elite actors within such
communities who are often playing their
own politics visa vie others who might
have other kinds of agendas or perhaps
actually you know see seek a different
kind of relationship to the problem I
mean certainly in oaxaca city and in
mexico city because we did a lot of
fieldwork in both of those locations to
talking to bureaucrats and government
officials bankers corporate officials
certainly the resistance is cast as kind
of the classic vanguard asst
troublemaking middle class rallying the
indigenous peasant class to you know to
their own desires and sort of funneling
those energies that that is the
accusation that is held against them
unsurprisingly i think in terms of
indigenous sort of battles between
different indigenous populations i mean
one of the things that people described
a lot of times with that this was a new
form of alliance between two indigenous
groups that had historically been at
loggerheads and had had been conflicted
for literally hundreds of years and
that's the WHA they who who live closer
to the ocean in the end the lagoon
Illaria and the zapotec which are much
more populous and much more powerful
indigenous group in the recent region so
one of the things we heard a lot is that
you know resistance to the wind park has
actually brought these two groups
together in a way that they never were
before so that is the claim that there's
that there's a new kind of cohesion and
alliance between these these groups
however I mean we mentioned that it was
teachers you know who began and the job
of being
teacher in Mexico is a is a very good
job right maybe it's not highly paid but
it's secure it's a relatively good
government job and so you know some of
these leaders who don't like to be
called leaders are in fact middle class
and some of the people in the resistance
are quite middle class so I don't think
we want to portray this as you know
entirely marginalized populations but
some some people are but the interesting
thing was that when they started to like
because we didn't talk about this a lot
but there was a lot of intimidation a
lot of violence directed against this
movement and actually you know to the
company's credit I think the company
that Chapman who said like we have told
that all of our allies do not hurt
anyone if we see you hurting people
we're going to walk away because that's
not what our shareholders and so forth
wanted see and I think there's evidence
that they were actually not saying like
go out and by any means necessary you
know because they could have disappeared
most of these people they threaten them
they broke into the community radio
station destroyed the equipment but it
was never violence rarely violence
against people although there were a lot
of death threats still people took those
death threats seriously and disappeared
so a lot of these leaders who were the
sort of the teachers were gone for long
stretches of time in hiding in oaxaca
city in mexico city and other places
because they knew that there were sort
of local hit squads that were associated
with both the co SE and the pre factions
both of whom supported the park who were
after them and but yet the resistance
continued so there was there was
probably you know a kind of you know
organic intellectual presence here but
at the same time there was a obviously a
strong community support and buying
because no matter how many people they
kind of put on their watch list and
scared them into hiding the resistance
just seemed to grow so for whatever
that's worth
there was an excellent we balanced
presentation in the beginning you
mentioned sort of the claim that you
know once they get their money they'll
go away you also mentioned the
speculative resource rush in my own
research and energy transitions you see
a learning process occurring between
communities some of you know who where
the resistance sort of dissipates and
resolved and people do get paid in some
cases in other cases they don't but from
a comparative perspective where there
are some of these regions that you
showed on the map surrounding the marina
the morenia site where their cases where
people did get paid and the resistance
did go away could you say something
about the neoliberal success of that
yeah we had three basic case studies two
of failure and one is of success if you
will mourinho is one case study because
it was like the big thing that everyone
was focused on when we were there last
year but then we also looked at x2 peck
which was this community park project
that never was allowed to move forward
despite you know a lot of planning a lot
of legal challenges to existing laws and
the third one is loving to us it is next
to publix epic can you see this on items
and ventoso is right there that yellow
on 11 toast as a place is one of two
towns in this area that's completely
encircled by one parks now and we're all
of the growth is really been happening
love in tosa is also a migrant community
that's like a little over a hundred
years old and so there's not been like a
long set of connections to particular
land in that way also it's an area that
through a series of battles back in the
Cosa era became privatized so when exit
when when what's-his-name Salinas sort
of like ended the hero system and said
you can begin to privatize your land if
you choose to do so this area was one
that was privatized which meant that in
the case the company was dealing with
private landholders with specific plots
of land instead of dealing with the
whole community where half of it or more
felt that they had been disenfranchised
in the process and in those cases where
there was a private property regime it
worked better and people seem to be
happier although still in terms of the
general social benefits that have sort
of been promised they're still very slow
in coming because typically they'll put
you know they'll create some little like
a little children's park and then almost
all the money is going directly into the
and in the company says
we're paying the leaders and if the
leaders don't use it to build a health
care of thing what you know what's that
right you know why is that our business
but that's part of this what people you
know disagree with the model is that
there isn't like a stronger emphasis on
building you know community benefits and
in most of the cases if they had
actually the company had come in for a
couple of years and done a lot of
community work I think that there you
know it would have been a much different
process to what happened one of the
great statements that we got from a
government of state-level bureaucrat in
oaxaca city was that one of the reasons
that marina was such a debacle in the
midst of when it was happening is
because they threw so much money around
he's like the expectation is that
leaders will be given something that
they'll redistribute some of some of
that wealth to the communities they'll
probably keep some of it for themselves
i mean there's this understanding about
graft and corruption but that morenia in
fact sort of you know doubled tripled
quadrupled the amount of money that they
were sort of tossing into the hands of
the golpeado days and the guys and the
white trucks who would drive by at night
and do these death threats so and that's
one of the conditions one of the other
conditions is that in places in the
isthmus where you do have private
property there were people who got wind
of the wind parks early on and
surprisingly bought up tracts of land
that were basically you know unusable
for anything else like agriculture but
we're very suitable for placing turbines
and so one of these people has been
described as a supercut sigue if you
know what i would add epithet cacique is
sort of strongman leadership where you
dominate you know your local population
this guy's a super Cacique because he
bought up all this land and it's gaining
incredible wealth from the rents for
road placement for turbine placement etc
so again that's that inequality but
people know everyone in the region sort
of knows this person and knows the story
behind it so it's understood and so just
to emphasize what Dominic was saying
there's the distinction between
collectively held land and how that gets
managed and then wealth portioned and
the privately held land and you have it
all happening in this one little region
I mean
no nazo Del Mar is collectively held
land if you want to do anything on that
land you have to meet with the 300
Coleman arrows and get their agreement
about it but if you you know go over to
who cheat on you can do a contract with
a local landholder pay him his rent and
you're set so they're very different
models and so this case in morenia was
the first they were trying to negotiate
on the with communal communally held
land also I don't know from this came
across alvaro obregon is over here the
reason Alvaro is so important in the
story is because it is at the entrance
to the sandbar which is the only way
that the company could get its equipment
onto the sandbar except you know coming
by boat and had some strategies to come
by boat but there was a lot of reaction
to these docs being placed there too
because the very shallow waters and that
was going to have an environmental
impact and so if you remember if those
of you who read Tim Mitchell's excellent
both carbon democracy talks about the
choke points where coal miners could
like actually that like a lot of what we
think of being the sort of institutions
of social democracy can be chased back
to coal miners specifically in their
strikes because they could stop kohl's
very heavy and can only move in certain
ways and they could block you know rail
lines in ways they could extract
political concessions that other types
of union activity couldn't and in a way
Alvaro was able to do and they you know
actually they were willing to pay them
almost anything they wanted to back off
but he'd become at this point more than
about the money they really wanted to
send a signal and they wanted to sort of
they wanted and they were very very
afraid that this sort of like ultimate
safety net of the fish will disappear
with the building of the park and the
dredging a little dagoon so yeah
xed out to pack is that on here I don't
see it and then only only I'll go right
here it started pekus accepted but it
would be right it's kind of near there
it is noticeable yeah it's like in this
area cuz a little bit of it goes on to
who cheat on them too and then onijonah
dolgo which is right here so these are
all I'm in there they're all
spectacularly productive sites for go
back to the wind map you have to
understand like this the wind it weirds
like sort of purple and red is off the
chart win yeah that's right yeah of a
tropical storm force winds are blowing
like they like hundreds and hundreds of
trailers just get knocked over by this
wind it's incredibly fierce 18-wheel
trailer tractor trailers tried made the
report me the recording of everything
the interviews we did and so forth
almost impossible because all you got
was wind sound incredible and that's why
they want it in the other thing that you
should know is that the expected return
rate on an investment of a bank in this
region it took us a lot of detective
work to find this out but finally we
found a very friendly banker just walked
us through all the numbers fifteen
percent return on investment so in an
era in which what do you get in a bank
these days when you put it what's your
CD giving you point zero five percent
interest or something so if you could
get a virtually guaranteed fifteen
percent return like fine answers are
lining up I mean there's no shortage of
capital well you're ready to come into
this region because of that that's how
much energy and it's in part because
Mexico is incredibly high electricity
tariffs especially for businesses it
deeply discounts domestic use but keeps
very high levels for businesses and so
companies can can get a long-term fixed
rate which they like a little bit lower
than market and that's why they're
willing to sort of by agree to buy
electricity for 20 years from one of
these parks and it's cheaper and they
get a great profile they get a green /
they get to say we've gotten all this
you know so they're getting they're
getting a good deal symbolically and
financially and then you know this just
you know gives them the bank's like an
enormous return on investment that
they're very happy with
so you know you can see why the the
engine keeps moving and keeps looking
for a new space to acquire you know and
they started in this sort of more simple
sort of private property zones that
somebody was pointing out before but now
they're creasing Lee expanding towards
the community held lands to looking for
a new project yeah thank you for the
talk I really enjoyed it I was just
curious both in your presentation and
then also in the images it seems like
this is an extremely gendered political
economy and political practice right
there's lots of discussion about men
with their shirts off men with guns men
and back of trucks and even in the
images itself I think I maybe saw one
woman and she was Jenny next she wasn't
holding a sign but there was a child who
may be looked male was carrying a sign
so I wondered if you could just comment
briefly on the role of women's
participation in these kinds of
movements or what their yeah what their
role is in these kinds of politics
mm-hmm I mean compared to the work that
i did on gender and sexuality movements
in nicaragua it's incredibly masculine
gendered this project I mean for me
personally it was very noticeable how
much time we spent interviewing spending
time with men in these committees and
these assembly as so it is it's largely
gendered male but there are women who
are participating in the resistance and
they are incorporated through the kind
of predictable rubrics of Family and
preserver of tradition and culture right
so when we went to this protest in
Mexico City that you saw a couple of
slides from that women came they came on
the bus from the isthmus and they were
wearing very traditional clothes and
they wore those throughout the protest
in order to kind of signal their
indigeneity and it's not that they don't
also wear those clothes at home but it's
definitely marks out something different
in the urban metropolis of Mexico City
and makes a statement and so there was
actually one slide here that I included
because I'm
is kind of what I'm referring to but
there's one woman he was quite prominent
in the movement and she has got an
international recognition she was
involved in co say this radical student
movement back in the 1980s when she was
13 years old she's very leftist and
she's been involved in all kinds of
resistance for a long time and she is an
important figure head in the resistance
but you are correct that it is largely
gendered male thank you guys so much I
just wanted to ask what are the ways
that that the media has been involved in
making this resistance successful or
bringing it to light and are the
producers of that media these people
themselves in we're mobilizing or are
you seeing like journalists from Mexico
City coming to Oaxaca um could you
explain that role a little bit Oh media
go yes somebody did work on activism
before I did work on media so we tried
to bring in some of our you know
attentions and expertise there there was
a there was a lot going on and media
played a really important interesting
role in this one thing that the the
assembly a movement was very good at was
using social media particularly to
connect with each other and also and
also is a platform for producing I would
sort of a particular kind of
visualization of their own victimization
by the company you know anytime I
mentioned that you know they use pepper
spray and when they did videos and put
them on YouTube of women whose eyes were
tearing because they've just been pepper
sprayed and you know when there was a
guy who was beaten up and had his arm
broken and so that became part of it and
these images are very powerful as you
know and there are networks that are set
up throughout the world to get these and
so part of the way that this one woman
Bettina got so famous wasn't one part
because she had help from some canny
leftist activists in Mexico City but in
part because she was able to fit into a
certain slot of the
kind of and really played her part
extraordinarily well of being the the
voice of the indigenous you know the
sort of disappearing indigenous subject
and did tours of your issue into the
European Parliament she went had a tour
all across Europe not her this is not
she's another woman who was important in
the movement but I don't think we have a
picture of the Tiananmen but I bet if he
went into google and put in wind parks
Oaxaca but Tina would come up that's one
of the first orient you would see her so
she and that was a lot of what because
their strategy and was multi-pronged it
was have barricades in the Isthmus but
also place pressure on these companies
back home because one of the big
investors was the dutch pension fund
whose acronym i can't remember right now
GG PG GM and so they wanted to make sure
that the European press got tales of the
the way in which these green energy
projects were coming only at you know
sort of from the skin and the livelihood
of indigenous peoples because I knew
people in Europe would not be happy
about that so there was they got
journalists from the Dutch press to come
and write stories and there was a and ap
did a story on a two or two stories
maybe on it so they got some pretty high
level contact just by doing a fairly
good job of orchestrating media coverage
of the movement and it definitely I mean
it wasn't just twenty people's way more
than 20 people involved in this but it
wasn't thousands and thousands probably
either and they made themselves seem
much larger by very carefully
orchestrating Oh in the movie and then
they got these guys to do this really
really interesting on what to calls so
most viento like we really win if you
just type that in there's an
english-language version that Tulsa
tells part of this story of that
includes like you know some kind of
sophisticated graphics and things like
that that they put together with a
production company that sort of tells
the story of their fight against these
big predatory wind companies and then
that got out and it was shown we went to
a screening in oaxaca city it got to
mexico city it may have gotten even
farther on youtube it's hard to say so
they had they used all i think all the
media at their disposal in ways that
that were quite interesting again i
don't know whether that augurs anything
about the future of these types of
movements elsewhere in the world or
whether this was an isolated event but
it was quite impressive the resistance
and activists were very sophisticated in
their use of spectacle when he was just
describing and the ability to sort of
film something immediately loaded up
onto youtube and some form we actually
were the object of one of those
interventions at one point where we had
some video footage and then we were
contacted by someone saying you need to
you know give us this so that we can
edit it down and put it up onto youtube
right away so there was a real awareness
of that but i think the other important
piece of it is the national and the
state level press which is private and
institutionalized and also according to
journalists that we interviewed can be
purchased for a price this this was what
they described that so that at one point
during the resistance to marina we saw
the press coverage change pretty
dramatically from the press reports that
were coming out of mexico city in oaxaca
city all of a sudden marina was being
painted and much more positive and
flattering terms and as we talk to
journalists working journalists they
said well you know they purchased this
space they purchased the company has
purchased you know a better spin on on
what's happening so manipulation of the
press and of journalists there are lots
of stories of journalists who were being
flown to Spain to see how great wind
parks were in Spain there were stories
about journalists being provided very I
don't know Tony prostitutes and taken to
this is jai mean these were the stories
were they real we don't know but these
were the kind of rumors that were
circulating that the press was being
purchased at all different dimensions so
would you just quickly tell us about it
oh thank you thank you thank you and
sorry to be pitched that one out there
well do you get shortstack okay so you
know one of the things are facing and
doing and we're interested as we were
going along this project about what's
collaborative research and anthropology
today and thinking about new ways of
doing that because it's hard when you
know you
come the rubber hits the road of things
like you know tenure files and things
like that and like actually you could
both work really hard on an essay
together and only get half credit right
for it because it's shared and that's
especially a disincentive for junior
people who might be that people who
might actually be the most interested in
experimenting with new kinds of forms of
ethnographic research but yet this sort
of Alliance on the solo in Lone Ranger
journalists style even though we want to
study like globalization but you're
gonna study in one person so it's crazy
so that that you know that sort of
inspired for us thinking about how can
we do this in a way that would sort of
adequately like represent the
partnership that was involved in like
every aspect of we're there for almost
every encounter we're there at the same
time we talked about it constantly all
the work is very much it's impossible
really we have our own interests in our
own styles but we it's impossible to
separate this research material so we
thought we'll try to do something that
is unusual that will try to publish two
books about the same thing at the same
time which is hard sell to publishers
you can imagine without saying we're
going to do something also interesting
and so what it's going to be is each of
us have our own interest very briefly
you know mine is more sort of on power
and political power and energy power
intersecting yours is more on you know
authority ecology plan ecological ethics
so the and their ways there's a really
rich body mature you can easily get like
a book out of each but then we want to
publish them together as a single volume
but and our publisher came up with a
great idea like a Mad Magazine flip book
so it'll be have two front covers and no
back-cover and you can read it you know
you can read it when we flip it over and
read the other book if you or flip back
and forth of the book the printed medium
will be will be and we call that the
duaa graph right and then for the
electronic edition to create both
because we have a lot of video and audio
and things we'd like to add in to create
a kind of augmented electronic edition
that allows you to link between the two
books electronically so you can follow
characters and events that as we both
talk about them and follow them over
into the other hyperlinks in the ebooks
right with also he's the others suggest
as well doing commentaries like some
kind of meta commentary on our takes on
each other's take sort of things which I
don't know how that's
that could be the end of the partnership
I like it up to that point of it okay so
we'll see what happens with that but
some possibility of being able to sort
of react to that and and to be able to
create a new sort of materialization of
a collaborative research endeavor that
could serve if it was something that
work could serve as a kind of possible
prototype for future you know sorts of
forms of research so they'll both be
full-length books but shorter because
because books are becoming much shorter
now too so 80,000 90,000 words but sort
of standard length for a book but bound
together the other pieces we'd like to
do a website that has some of this
material so some of the video material
that we have audio recordings images
Maps I mean not you know unlimited
number of things but a kind of a
resource reservoir for people to use in
teaching or to see some of these places
and hear these voices that are in the
text itself so and all of this is
eminently doable according to Cornell
University Press the you know the the
software is there it's not difficult the
printing press can do this this flip
sided book for not one penny more than
it would cost to just print out a
regular book so it's yeah it's real so
it's not I mean this is a kind of an
interesting moment in lots of ways and
also connect you to the journal to you
know a moment to begin reimagining the
forms of anthropological publication and
communication actually have quite a lot
of technologies that our disposal if we
want to use them to realize some things
that people have been talking about for
a long time like wouldn't it be nice if
there was multimedia in this article
right if we could put in bed you know
video within a journal article or if we
could and you know imagine new forms of
you know augmented book experiences that
are principally web-based or even
methodologically to be able to do a
truly collaborative project from front
to finish but then at the end being able
to surface your own analysis and your
own argument as an individual right
without having to kind of negotiate or
boil it down or up depending on how you
want to look at it to a kind of
consensus agreement about what the case
study says because each of us have our
perspectives and our theoretical
orientations
to be able to surface that argument out
of a collaborative project i think is an
advantage to and might encourage more
collaborative research if you could if
there a way to do that if you could see
different participants voices in the
final products i think people might be
more amenable to this idea that it still
counts right because you can hear
because it was something like when you
write together there there can be a
tendency to kind of find the lowest
common denominator you can both agree on
but if you disagree which we did because
we had talked a lot only a different
interpretations of different events and
should not also be part of the record
right that two people who were in all
the same encounters still saw it
differently isn't that something that
should be part of the ethnography to all
right thank you so much